you know what they say
like father like son
if that wasn't enough to get your
midichlorians pumping i don't know what
is
we have the season finale of the
mandalorian and along with it brand new
theories on where the show is headed
as well as a post-credit sequence
revealing a show that wasn't even
announced at star wars investors day
shut up and take my money so make sure
to like and subscribe and stick around
till the end of the episode because
we'll be talking about what's going on
with ahsoka tano
moff gideon and what mando's acquiring
of the dark saber could mean for
season three now let's get into it
chapter 16 the last of season two is
directed by peyton reed the same
director as
chapter 10 and marvel's ant-man and
fittingly enough it's called the rescue
as
mando and the team prepare to capture
grogu after successfully acquiring moff
gideon's coordinates but you can't just
go up to an imperial cruiser willy-nilly
they need a plan it's never explained in
the show how this happens but
boba and the slave 1 have tracked down
dr pershing
being escorted in an imperial shuttle
we've seen these ships before in the
star wars universe and palpatine also
gets off one in return of the jedi
it's possible that pershing is being
escorted away from moff gideon here as
we find out later in the episode
moff no longer needs grogu he's got what
he wanted
in the form of his blood holding the
crew hostage one of the imperial pilots
refers to cara as a dropper which is
just another word for a shock trooper
which is exactly what she used to be the
pilot was also on the original death
star from a new hope
as he mentioned he was there during the
destruction of alderaan
kara's home planet destroying your
planet was a small price to pay
to rid the galaxy of terrorism it really
harkens back to what last episode was
trying to say
that no matter what side you're on
you'll either be painted as a freedom
fighter or a terrorist in order to
spring grogu
mando is going to need some muscle which
is why he tracks down boko tan and koska
who we previously met in chapter 11.
no mention is made of where their other
partner axe woves is in exchange for
their help
beau wants a lot she wants boba's slave
1 in their effort to retake mandalore
moths a dark saber which can cut through
anything but pure baskar
and for mando to reconsider joining
their efforts all of which he agrees to
this is all part of what i think the
main storyline of season 3 will be
and i'll get to that in a bit during
this not so peaceful bargaining boba and
koska get in a tussle mainly over what
it means to be mandalorian
bo and koska don't think boba is a real
mandalorian
you are not a mandalorian he's a clone
of jango fett after all but fermando
himself this has been his major
character arc this season whereas in
season one mando went from solo
bounty hunter wanting nothing to do with
the kid too willing to sacrifice his
life for him
season two sees mando's arc take shape
in a different form that centers around
his beliefs in the mandalorian code
in chapter 11 for example he tells bo
she's not a real mandalorian because she
takes off her helmet
something he'll end up doing so that
grogu can take one final look at him
before they separate
mando is learning to put his feelings
towards others above what
beau would call a fanatical code
indoctrinated in mando as a child
so the plan they come up with is quite
simple create a diversion so that mando
can sneak in
and retrieve the child when all is said
and done they'll reconvene on that
imperial bridge
so they use the lambda imperial shuttle
and boba's slave 1 to trick the imperial
cruiser in letting them land
the only problem is they have to be
quick once they're discovered moff
gideon will unleash his third generation
dark troopers and these guys are no joke
the shuttle crash lands in the launch
tube and that's the last we'll see of
boba fett this episode
well until we get to that post-credits
scene more on that in a bit
team one comprised of fenix shand cara
dune bokeh tan and koska make quick work
of the stormtroopers as they make their
way to the bridge
and provide mando with a distraction
bonus points if you caught this ra7
protocol droid like the one
seen in a new hope in the nick of time
mando is able to stop the dark troopers
from entering the main hallway well
all but one and we get to see just how
powerful these droids are
literally bashing mando's best gar steel
helm into the side of the hall he's
gonna need some tylenol after that
blaster shots fire and even his
whistling bird salvo
barely face the dark trooper and this is
just one
imagine a platoon of them mando is
tossed around like a ragdoll but the
only thing that seems to stop the dark
trooper is
mando's pure best car steel spear he
obtained in chapter 13
that formerly belonged to magistrate
morgan ellsmith on corvus a spear he was
rewarded for helping ahsoka tano in
liberating the people of kaladin while
the other team makes quick work of
commandeering the bridge
mando finds moff gideon holding groku
hostage
again this theme of who is good and who
is evil is echoed by gideon who says
that mando and his team have already
butchered
dozens of his men so who really is the
bad guy here
maf gideon tells mando that the child
has rare properties that have the
potential to bring order back to the
galaxy but that he no longer
needs him because he has his blood he
also talks about the darksaber and that
whomever wields it has the right to lay
claim to the mandalorian throne
and i'll get to this in a bit but this
is what i think season 3 will focus on
moff agrees to let the child go as long
as mando leaves the ship
but this agreement is short-lived as
moff gideon attacks mando from behind
engaging in a battle that demonstrates
the power of the saber
as it cuts through the steel frame of
the ship mando however ends up besting
moff gideon and
bringing him to boca ten at the bridge
it's here that it's revealed that mando
can't simply hand over the saber the one
thing bokutan wants more than anything
else
in order for her to wield the darksaber
again
she would need to defeat you in combat
if bo katan is going to take her place
as ruler of mandalore she must obtain
the darksaber through combat but before
the issue can be settled
the team is notified of the impending
dark troopers yeah the ones that got
swept out the airlock are on their way
back and moff gideon is like
you had your hands full with one
let's see how you do against a platoon
this platoon of dark troopers quickly
makes their way to the bridge blast
doors pummeling their way through
when another unexpected visitor in an
x-wing boards the cruiser donning his
iconic cape and green lightsaber it's
none
other than luke skywalker who you could
probably guess before his face reveal by
his one glove covered robotic hand
his entrance on the cruiser is just like
how his father tore through the rebel
ship
in rogue one luke cuts through the dark
troopers like butter and the strength of
the force can be seen as he force
crushes one of the dark trooper's
powerful armor
luke's arrival pretty much confirms that
he was the person grogu was
communicating with on tython grogo even
reaches out to him through the security
cameras
and we know that the force can be used
to communicate with others and
masters of it can even astral project
luke has arrived to take the child and
train him
he is strong with the force but talent
without training is nothing
manto takes off his helmet something
that he would normally never do
for one last tearful goodbye saying that
he'll one day see him again
and as far as i know this is the first
time he's ever let
someone else touch his face luke picks
up grogu taking him away to begin their
training
we even get a little r2d2 cameo luke's
x-wing here i can't help but think is
the same one that will eventually end up
submerged on act 2. but all this raises
the question
what happens between now and luke's
training of kylo ren
remember that master yoda's dying wish
was for luke to train a new generation
of jedi
and grogu would have been his first
apprentice before kylo ren since
luca didn't take kylo in until he was 10
years old and kylo would have only been
about 4 years old
during the events of the mandalorian so
we basically have
6 unaccounted for years where we don't
know what happens
i also have a feeling that season 3
won't focus on the child and is training
with luke and there's a few reasons i
have for this
one there's only so much you can show of
luke training him at such a young age
without it kinda looking goofy i mean
it's cute as hell but grogu can barely
walk two the way this was shot with the
music and everything
really made it seem that this was a
final departure and it wouldn't be for a
long time that we see mando and the
child reunited three it's just damn
expensive to cgi a young luke skywalker
plus i didn't find the d
aging that convincing like it was
passable but if they were to focus on
him as a storyline for season 3
they'd have to spend way more time on it
but the biggest reason i think we won't
see grogu much next season
is that they have set up a different
storyline for mando altogether
and that's him and the battle for
mandalore i think that season three will
focus on taking back the planet and his
eventual confrontation with boca tan we
already know that they have differing
views on what it means to be a
mandalorian and apparently he just can't
give it to her the thing that gives one
legitimacy to the throne without being
defeated by her
and this defeat likely means to the
death another thread that could be
picked up on is moff gideon
the last we see of him is being knocked
out by car doon who said she wanted him
alive as he may have valuable info for
the new republic we still don't know how
far his experiments went with grogu and
if his experiments with dr pershing were
given to someone else like palpatine or
grand admiral thrawn speaking of thrawn
there's the lingering question of ahsoka
tano
who we now know is getting her own
spin-off show many were wondering if
ahsoka would show up in this episode but
it looks like her story will pick up
with her
series that will focus on her hunting
down thrawn
and speaking of spin-offs we have our
post-credits sequence
welcome back to jabba's palace which we
last saw in return of the jedi
remember that jabba has been dead for
several years now after being killed by
leia
and it looks like bib fortuna also from
return of the jedi has taken over as
leader of what remains of the hutt
cartel bonus points if you overheard him
say the word mcclunky the hattie's word
greedo says just before he's shot
which roughly translates to this will be
the end of you
bib has also gained a few pounds in this
time but hey i'm not here to body shame
fenix shand and boba fett arrive having
fulfilled their duty to mando by
reuniting him with the child
boba kills bib with a blaster shot and
takes his place on the throne of jabba's
palace setting us up for a new spin-off
called the book of boba fett now this is
a huge surprise it wasn't even announced
a few days prior at disney's investor
day
with all the other new shows but i can't
help but think that this is what the
former star wars
underworld tv series has kinda morphed
into so there you have it for season two
a very open-ended one
leaving the show with vast possibilities
on where to go next
and even with the pandemic season 3 is
apparently still
on schedule for a late 2021 release so
get yourselves in cryo
and i'll see you then thanks for
watching everyone please make sure to
like and subscribe and follow me on
twitter and instagram
at think story yt until next time
remember
i have spoken
you